et oui sujet compliqué c'est très
compliqué smartphone génial sujet
extrêmement compliqué on parle
aujourd'hui du mec 30 pro de huawei
mettront pro qui est ici qui était
présenté il ya quelques temps et mes 30
ans qui souffre d'une guerre entre les
états unis et la chine lié à la 5g et au
milieu de ça vous avez huawei alors
c'est compliqué parce qu'on a un produit
qui est vraiment très très bon dans
plein de domaines l'écran la photo
l'expérience globale c'est un produit
qui est vraiment très beau très aboutie
qui est le produit le plus abouti de
weck est lent vrai petit bijou
technologique qui pourrait être une
référence s'il n'y avait pas ce problème
de google savait pas ce problème de
plextor s'il n'y avait pas ce problème
du fait que vous ne pouvait strictement
rien installer des services google
enfin strictement à un détail près
[Musique]
j'ai bien commencé les vidéos commençant
par un détail près en fait vous pouvez
installer c'est possible d'installer le
plextor vous pouvez recettes toutes les
applications après gmail youtube et
compagnie mais c'est du domaine de la
débrouille c'est du domaine de la
bricole et derrière y'a rien qui me
semble en tout cas être extrêmement
viable j'ai fait le choix de ne pas vous
montrer cela ça y est j'ai installé une
plaie store pour voir un petit peu
comment ça marche et mais je sais pas
convaincu en termes de sécurité derrière
parce que vous passez par un stade de
bisous et alors je pars au maître de
lien pour vous dire comment le faire
comme on le télécharge et comment
l'installer si vous pouvez le faire si
vous voulez le faire vous pouvez le
faire parce que vous trouverez sur
internet
vous cherchez sur google sur youtube
vous trouve très facilement mais moi je
vous le recommande pas pour deux raisons
principales la première c'est qu'on n'y
a pas de licence android sur ce
smartphone là je pourrais vous montrer
un système pour l'installer mais qui
n'est globalement pas dans les clous pas
dans les règles je pourrais aller à
l'encontre des règles de youtube en vous
montrant un système qui me semble être
un petit peu bancal qui n'est pas du
piratage mais que voilà je suis parce
que c'est le premier point est deuxième
point c'est que je peux pas garantir la
sécurité
je peux pas vous garantir qu'ils aient
pas de backdoor pas vous garantir que
vos infos seront complètement protégé
donc je veux pas vous pousser là dessus
de port vous inciter à le faire sachez
que si vous êtes bricoleur vous voulez
tester que vous voulez le faire vous
pouvez le faire mais je ne vous le
recommande pas néanmoins je les fais je
les installe et moi j'ai pris le risque
et je pars me dont google que j'utilise
moi personnellement j'ai un compte hier
que j'utilise pour des cas comme ça et
qui du coup fonctionne j'ai installé ge
you tube
j'ai le plein ce tort j'ai pu
télécharger des applications ça
fonctionne à merveille absolument aucun
problème d'ailleurs on a soit elle qui
est extrêmement puissant sinon ça dans
quelques instants dans les semaines
derrière on va le regarder directement
dans vous allez voir sa chronique est
vraiment cool très puissant qui marche
parfaitement bien mais qui souffre qui
souffrent de ce problème de placer alors
ce prime de plextor je suis pas sûr
qu'il se résolve aujourd'hui de toute
façon c'est un smartphone qui n'a pas
l'air google smartphone qui devra pas la
licence google on se met derrière on
regarde ça ensemble
c'est un produit que je trouve très bien
abouti notamment au niveau de l'écran
lors ya des personnes qui n'aimeront pas
forcément l'écran qui va vraiment ce
côté mais soupe que moi ça prend
vraiment de la profondeur et la qualité
de lecture après ce que j'avais fait un
petit peut survenir chipoter c'est qu'on
a 7 ans koshla gens préféraient n'est
pas avare d'encoches on arrive sur les
techno en 2020 où effectivement les
caméras sont planqués sous l'écran pour
l'instant ils sont encore là donc on est
dans les standards de 2010
9 rien d'étonnant là dessus petit bord
en bas en haut c'est bien je vous dis on
a vraiment le cran qui vient lécher sur
le côté qui est extrêmement bien fini
très bien aboutie beau boulot on
retrouvera en tout cas très bizarre sa
garde et vous avez le bouton ici son
côté qui est quand même vachement
déporté sur le bas forcément que vous
avez les cons qui arrive là c'est
surprenant mais c'est pas mal on trouve
très facilement se doit voyez on trouve
très facilement sa sa position et ce qui
est très sympa et surprenant s'il prend
un coup mais ça c'est rigolo
si vous n'êtes pas de bouton de volume
revenir activer les volumes double tape
son côté d'un côté ou de l'autre vous
avez un retour à petit on sent vraiment
sous le doigt dans ce bien je trouve ça
assez rigolo d'un côté ou de l'autre
voyez bon c'est cool ce principe ça
c'est rigolo ça c'est limite si vous
voulez par exemple très facilement vos
questions vous pouvez pas il faut le
prendre le déverrouiller le maudit c'est
comme ça bon il ya des inconvénients des
avantages si rigolo en tout cas ce que
nous montrons pas où est l'astuce un
tour de force technologique smartphones
qui derrière rossi est plutôt bien fait
assez bien aboutie doc est joli appareil
photo en partenariat avec les écarts non
pas dans quelques instants de
l'infrarouge micro réduction de bruit de
la recharge en usb c'est les cartes sim
se trouve là le micro le haut parleur
produit qui est très sympa et surtout
qu' un écran qui est vraiment incroyable
6,53 pouces 2400 par 1176 xl à 409
pixels par pouces un écran oled ratio
19.5 ne vienne comme installer le
plextor j'ai installé youtube
j'ai donc ma vidéo voyez par exemple à
dans une qualité qui est vachement cool
au niveau de la vidéo assez surprenant
dauphin voyez vraiment venir appuyer sur
le côté pour retrouver son bouton de
volume
vous avez le haut parleur l'a qui
fonctionne plutôt bien expérience de
visionnage est quand même vachement cool
ça marche très très bien on est le
superbe qualité l'écran est vraiment
extrêmement bien bien maîtrisé les
couleurs sont top
les contrastes sont magnifiques les
noirs sont accueillis cette oreille en
termes de performances d'un truc est
vachement bien aussi ce temps karine 992
avait de l'intelligence artificielle 8
gigas de ram 128 giga de stockage
l'autonomie monstrueux avec une grosse
batterie de 4500 millions terreur mais
jusqu'à 2
absolument aucun problème sur
l'autonomie vous avez de la recharge
rapide 40 watts filaire et 27 watts en
adduction vous avez la recharge inversée
aussi le web et par vaux chargé à notre
smartphone recharger des écouteurs
m'offrit boltro ce que vous voulez donc
ça s'est vraiment bien comme ont un
smartphone hyper performant ça va très
très bien pour les jeux pour le gaming
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment top
comme je vous disais pour l'audio on
trouve ici un haut parleur mono point de
technologies ça fait deux ici l'audio
c'est à dire du faux qui vient de
dessous de son écran pour venir apporter
plus d'immersion 500 vous comme ça ça ne
paraît pas complètement dingue j'ai
passé la sensation d'immersion j'ai
vraiment apprécié d'avoir su haut
parleurs plutôt mono sur le côté
néanmoins en terme d'expérience ça
fonctionne et même si effectivement il
ya pas de licence google vous avez quand
même un androïde 10 vous avez une
version d'android mais sans la licence
google dont vous n'avez pas le plextor
en gros c'est la différence néanmoins
vous avez votre android 10 avec la
surcouche m8 10.00 vous avez donc tout
votre android vous allez pouvoir
utiliser vous le voyez d'ailleurs que
vous avez dans à propos du téléphone
vous le voyez c'est indiqué juste ici
version d'android c'est la numéro 10
donc vous trouvez votre android
si vous êtes habitué e andreu de vous
serez pas perdu vous retrouver
exactement les mêmes fonctionnalités
mises à part effectivement là monsieur
vous n'avez pas de plextor au niveau de
la photo on va rester dans ce que ces
phares huawei un photophone qui marche
extrêmement bien vous le voyez si vous
regardez à l'arrière vous avez quatre
capteurs photo premier capteur photo ça
te plait pas principal 40 mégapixels
ouvre à f 1.6 deuxième capteur photo 5
40 mégapixels également qui ouvre à f
1.8 c'est le très grand-angle vous avez
le troisième capteur photo de 8
mégapixels téléobjectif ouvre à f 2.4
on parle dans une optique x 3 jusqu'à
zoom numérique four 30 et vous avez une
caméra tough qui l'a notamment pour la
profondeur de champ à l'avant vous avez
une caméra de cette fille qui
planquaient la lorien carrière ses films
il n'y a pas qu'une caméra de celle
fille vous avez aussi une caméra de
celle filtrante de millas pixels qui
ouvre à f 2.0 vous avez aussi une caméra
pts off qui vous servira pour de la
navigation avec vos gestes
nous allons pouvoir scrollé directement
sur votre smartphone avec votre main et
ça va aussi servir pour mode portrait
pour la profondeur de champ donc ça
aussi ça marche très très bien
il vous pouvez faire du slow motion
jusqu'à 7680 images par seconde à 720p
c'est un truc complètement incroyable et
en 1080p vous pouvez aller jusqu'à 900
60 images par seconde
vous vous en douterez la photo c'est un
des points forts de huawei on l'avait
déjà que le pétrole prendre aux
trouvailles comme et rompre ou la canne
et c'était pas mal de photos dans le
métro station gambetta le rendu
aimant bien la maîtrise des lumières si
vous regardez le bleu derrière les
lumières bleues regardez c'est très très
juste ça marche vachement bien contenir
certains grands dangers tels bouger un
peu c'est un peu flou on continue
ensuite alors j'ai fait le zoom jusqu'à
x 30 bon c'est pas extraordinaire c'est
zoom aussi pousser ça permet de montrer
ce qu'on est capable de faire en termes
de technologie c'est pas ouf
mais ça marche en extérieur ça marche
vachement bien regardez moi ça donc il
ya une très très bonne gestion de la
plage dynamique étendue travaux en
attendant une petite différence au
niveau de la colorimétrie mais ça
fonctionne ça va plutôt pas mal
on entend à venir zoom est directement
dans l'image ça marche on progresse dans
le zoom on avance on avance est
notamment exposé une fois 30 bon une
fois de plus c'est pas soient faits pour
ça mais ça fonctionne on est uni photos
en extérieur temps de pluie à paris ça
fonctionne
l'ultra grand temps qu'on va quand même
cette petite différence au niveau des
arbres au niveau des feuilles
la différence se fait au niveau de la
colorimétrie quand on part d'un objectif
à l'autre on va venir chercher un peu
plus avec le jour on avance le foie
sorte une fois de plus c'est pas ouf on
va faire ensuite de la photo
d'alimentation ça marche moi je trouve
que vraiment le rendu est très très très
très très qualitatif et sur la photo de
nuit ça marche aussi extrêmement bien
belle plage dynamique surtout toute la
gestion au niveau des éclairages là au
niveau du point sombre 3 ça marche bien
on admet que les races de tour eiffel et
on va très très bien derrière les nuages
donc c'est vraiment bien tous les
reflets dans l'eau sont juste les
bateaux à tous les détails des petites
flaques d'eau devant c'est vraiment très
très très bon ça marche extrêmement bien
peut-être un problème de stabilisation
niveau de l'ultra grand temps tels que
c'est pas mais extrêmement dingue on va
venir chercher avec le zoom en fait un
peu plus ça marche ça fonctionne on se
rapproche
bon tout était à côté un petit peu plus
lisse et c'est un peu moins bosser pour
avoir tout d'un peu plus propre mais ça
fait le taf
ça fait vraiment le taf bon la tour
eiffel enfants 30 la nuit c'est pas
terrible terrible du tout mais regardez
ça marche très très bien là sur le champ
les éclairages on les a c'est vraiment
bien c'est très juste
je trouve qu une fois de plus une très
très belle maîtrise de la part de huawei
au niveau de la photo de nuit sauf quand
on cherche évidemment avec le zoom suis
un petit peu moins terrible l'obélisque
ça c'est vachement beau râler mossala la
tour eiffel dans les nuages
bon on a forcément tout de suite c'est
un petit peu moins terrible dès qu'on
s'approche et là on va directement à
hawaï je vous ai fait des plans
magnifiques pour vous ramener un petit
peu de chaleur regardez-moi ça comme
c'est incroyable les détails sur les
palmiers le soleil l'eau les reflets
d'or vous avez beaucoup lumière ça
l'appareil qui absolument extraordinaire
on continue j'ai changé légèrement j'ai
fait un focus un peu plus sur noir là
dessus ça marche quand même drôlement
bien différentes expos c'est vraiment
cool
le rendu très très juste même sur un
coucher de soleil regarder ça c'est
vraiment tout simplement purement
incroyable il ya vraiment une très très
belle fille ça s'inscrit dans ce conte
avec le p 31 au niveau du photophone
c'est sensiblement la même chose un peu
au dessus quand même par rapport au p 30
mais en termes de photos en termes de
qualité c'est vraiment un produit
extraordinaire je vous dis tout de suite
et vous arrivez sur le zoom x 30
c'est pas de karim c'est vraiment fait
pour le côté un peu whaou le côté whaou
on en prend plein les yeux
mais dans la réalité c'est pas dingue
c'est pas d'un faux pas et c'est un jeu
que je me choisissent et bien au delà
c'est pas terrible mais voyez on a quand
même des rangs du qui sont
exceptionnelles on est sur un smartphone
il faut très clairement le savoir donc
ça montre toute la force de huawei là
dessus au niveau de la r&d c'est
complètement incroyable c'est un
smartphone que du bluetooth cinq points
du amc qui est certifié ip 68 résistants
à l'eau et à la poussière est un très
très beau produit une très belle
finition un produit très sympa que je
trouve vraiment cool mais que
malheureusement je peux pas forcément
venir vous recommander aujourd'hui à
cause de ce problème de plextor je sais
pas ce que vous en recettes dites moi
vraiment vous ce que vous en pensez
comment vous trouvez est ce que vous
pourriez acheter ce smartphone tout en
sachant qu'il n'ya pas le plextor et les
services google installé dessus
est ce que vous vous sentiriez vous
capable est-ce que voudriez prendre le
risque d'aller installer le plextor par
un système de miloudi h tiers est ce que
vous pourriez vous dire ok il n'ya pas
le placer ok je vais utiliser les
services de huawei au niveau de l'europe
galerie j'utilisais les services
d'amazon utiliser des services tiers
pour récupérer des applications sachant
qu' il ya des choses que je n'aurais pas
notamment youtube gmail et compagnie
alors rassurez vous quand même si vous
avez une adresse gmail et vous voulez
utiliser le centre ancien mec dessus
vous pouvez le faire sur un autre client
que le client gmail c'est possible sans
aucun problème je sais pas voilà dites
moi ce que vous en pensez comment vous
trouvez ce smartphone est ce qui
pourrait malgré tout ça vous intéresser
est-ce que vous pensez que huawei un
produit qui est vraiment top 10 il est
est ce que vous espérez qu'en 2020 la
situation se débloque pour profiter de
produits qui sont vraiment toujours très
très bien abouti tout ça en barrant
commentaire quant à nous on se retrouve
dès demain nous en masse à des machos